hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down all of the latest
developments
in the black clover story including
noel's grand
entrance onto the battlefield the
aftermath
of dante's battle with magna and the
beginning
of the true end game as the real final
villains take
center stage we've got a bunch of things
to talk about so let's get into it
as always if you guys enjoyed the black
lover content here on the channel and
you want us to keep it going just leave
a quick like
and comment it only takes a second and
it's a totally free way to support
the channel and if you're new to anime
out pro or maybe you watch our videos
but you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications if you
don't go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all you're still gonna miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed it's
just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror finally this video will of
course contain black clover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned
we start off in the aftermath of the
epic showdown between magna and
dante dante is down and out
and magna himself is barely standing
zora has to basically hold him up
physically so he doesn't fall over and
of course zora congratulates magna
on this amazing victory hosta luck and
knocked
then approach magna and zora and both
host and luck are absolutely amazed by
magna's accomplishment
osta calls magna a true man and luck
says that he looks forward to
fighting magna sometime in the future
magna is definitely down for that
and he promises that he will win i find
that a bit hard to believe
knowing how strong luck is right now but
then again i never thought that magnet
could defeat dante so i am not about to
count this man
out meanwhile jack is also stunned by
what he has just witnessed
as a commoner himself albeit one with an
incredible magic attribute
he has a ton of appreciation for what
magna has been able to accomplish
and jack is also impressed with yami for
being able to see the hidden potential
in someone like magna yami really is an
exceptional
captain and the best way to see that is
in the development of the people that he
has recruited
but as everyone is celebrating magna's
truly incredible victory
somewhere below morris is still actively
summoning more and more
devils from the underworld morris senses
that dante has lost
and he wonders what magic was used to
defeat
him morris does not seem worried at all
by dante's defeat
which tells me that he has a master plan
that is still very much on track
because it doesn't really involve dante
this brief scene with
morris reminds us yet again that until
our heroes can take
morris down and completely close the
cliff off portal
they are just going to keep facing more
and more devils and the devils that they
face are only going to get
stronger dante may have been defeated
but dante was certainly not
the only threat and the real final
battle against the strongest clifford
devils
is only just beginning with that said
though defeating dante was still an
important step
without dante the cliff off cannot
function at full capacity
at least that's what noct believes but
noct also warns everyone that the
cliffhoth won't stop functioning
altogether
until the other two members of the dark
triad are defeated
the gang then eats some healing crackers
in order to recover at least a bit of
their strength
and then they all head out in search of
the other dark triad members
but after they all leave dante's body
magic
suddenly goes berserk dante looks
deranged like he's not all there
and his body begins to morph in wild and
monstrous ways
jack is still there in the room and he
says that while dante's regeneration
magic
is incredible dante has now lost all
control of it
his magic is no longer stable enough for
dante to use properly
and in fact dante's entire body may be
disintegrating before our
eyes jack vows that he won't let
whatever is left of dante sour
magnus victory and so he proceeds to cut
dante we don't get to see exactly what
happens after that
but it is implied that dante has lost
control both of his mind
and of his magic and the jack is about
to put him out of his misery once and
for all
does this mean that dante is going to
straight up die off screen
maybe but maybe not i wonder if lucifer
is going to be able to somehow hijack
dante's body
and use his body magic to essentially
create a new body for himself
that would mean that dante himself is
effectively gone and what's left of his
body will actually be serving as
lucifer's body at least temporarily
definitely let me know what you guys
think is going to happen to dante
down in the comments did he just die off
screen
can he actually survive even after
losing control of his magic
or is his body about to be hijacked by
lucifer as
austin and the others rush through the
palace corridors in search of the other
dark triad members
we see that charlotte and rill are still
fighting vanica
charlotte and rill haven't been able to
take vanica down
both because of her incredibly powerful
blood magic and also because she is
using poor princess lotopachica as a
human shield
in fact not only is vanica using lore
pachika as a hostage and a human shield
she is also apparently using megicula's
curse to control
loro pechika's body this means that
venica not only has her own blood magic
and megicula's curse magic
under her command but she also has lord
pachika's extremely powerful
water magic at her disposal and of
course
the fact that manika is controlling
water pachica's body means that
charlotte and real cannot go
all out in this fight because they don't
want to accidentally hurt a lot of
pachica
as a result vanica is dominating the
fight
and just as it looks like she is about
to kill charlotte
noel and gaia come to the rescue our
girl noel
attacks vanica head on while gaia grabs
the possessed loro pachika
noel then screams at vanica that she has
arrived
just as promised and you better believe
that we are hyped for this
epic rematch noel deserves her moment to
shine
and she deserves revenge against vanica
and magikula as vanica smiles like the
crazy yandere that she is
the chapter ends this was a quick
transition chapter that sets up the
coming final battle
but it still featured some incredible
and potentially important moments
the big rematch between noel and vaneka
is going to be
insane not only because we're going to
see a bunch of truly epic magic
attributes clashing against each other
but also because there is so much
emotional weight to this fight
noelle's mother was apparently killed by
megicula
now her friend was kidnapped and is
being controlled by manika and megikula
like some sort of zombie
and i know that we are about to see some
truly show-stopping moments here
we can definitely expect some new
power-ups and maybe even a brand new
transformation from noel
which is gonna be amazing and we might
finally learn
more about megikula and this devil's
connection to
aussie a silva since we know that makila
likes to come out and take control of
anika's body even when vanika doesn't
necessarily want that to happen
i can totally see megikula taking
control by force
if venice starts losing and that is when
we finally might get an assier silva
backstory i've always felt that there
was more to the assiere and megickla
story than meets the eye
so i hope that i will be proven right
during this fight
i am also curious to see what will
ultimately become of dante
or rather what will become of what's
left of him and what about xenon
can he prove to be a tougher opponent
than dante or will he also falter once
he is faced with the full power
of the clover kingdom crew personally i
think that the real villain to watch
right now is morris and also whichever
highest ranked devil
emerges from the gate of clifford next
i've been saying for many months that
the dark triad are not going to be the
final villains of this arc
the final villains will likely be the
strongest devils including lucifer
and potentially morris himself morris
has already proven himself to be
incredibly sneaky
intelligent and dangerous and it is
likely that he has been manipulating the
dark triad
all along in order to get what he wants
even though he sensed that dante was
defeated
morris wasn't worried at all which tells
me that he has something else planned
something much bigger than the dark
triad but let me know what you guys
think who will end up being the final
villain
and how will the final battle unfold is
the dark triad themselves going to
remain
relevant or are they going to be
upstaged by morris lucifer
and the other highest ranked devils
finally do you think that there is more
to the story about ossier silva
and her death at the hands of megikula
definitely share your thoughts down in
the comments below
if you enjoyed this black lower video
and you want to see more content here on
the channel please leave that like to
let me know it only takes a second but
it helps a lot
and if you are new to anime opera or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at anime uproar a big thank you to all
of our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and red
haired raven
these guys are absolute mad lads and
disciples
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
al-jatal dr cortman the toasted chi ry
carlo
slickback emperor otaku spidey life
chanel tungsten tarquez baked buddhist
and cody hebert
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky cricket xp
very gucci alicia octor bonnie park
sinokami and water 10 no ted
isparky65 joanne garcia fat boy games
metal mama corey mcgowan deadly saint
soul ray slice and dice and pillow if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you